foreign
project for your resume in today's
competitive job market having hands-on
experience in devops projects can
significantly enhance your employability
in this video we will guide you through
a step-by-step process of creating
practical devops projects that you can
proudly showcase on your resume whether
you are a beginner or an experienced
Health Enthusiast these projects will
help you level up your skills and make
you stand out to potential employers so
let's get started before we dive into
the projects let's quickly review what
devops is all about so devops is the
amalgamation of software development and
IIT operation practices it focuses on
collaboration Automation and continuous
delivery to achieve faster and more
Reliable Software releases building
personal devs projects offer numerous
benefits for your career growth it
showcases your ability to apply a Dev
principles in real world scenarios
proving your practical knowledge to
potential employers additionally these
projects demonstrate your passion for
self-learning and keeping up with the
latest industry Trends and before we
begin if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in
devops by graduating from the best
universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers so it devops
by learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learn scatic
post-graduate programming devops and the
link for this course is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete order of the program
being offered and if these are the types
of videos you would like to watch then
hit the Subscribe button like and press
on the Bell icon to never miss out
further content so stay tuned with us
until the end of this video and don't
forget to register your opinion in the
comment section below now let's start
with some beginner level devops project
so our first project is improve Jenkins
remoting the improved Jenkins remoting
project is a crucial initiative in the
devops Run aimed at enhancing the
efficiency and reliability of Jenkins
remoting function personality Jenkins is
a widely used automation server in the
devops ecosystem serving as the backbone
of continuous integration and continuous
delivery CI CD pipelines the project
centers around identifying addressing
and optimizing issues related to Jenkins
remoting thereby elevating the overall
performance and user experience now
coming to project objectives so what
this project needs to be done the first
is to enhance security
so to strengthen the security measures
of Jenkins remoting to safeguard against
potential online abilities and
unauthorized access Implement secured
communication protocols and
authentication mechanisms for better
data protection the next objective is
improve performance identify performance
bottlenecks in the remoting system and
optimize a resource utilization to
minimize latency and speed up the build
process conduct load testing to assess
the system's capability and scalability
and the next is stability and
reliability address any known stability
issues in the Jenkins remote conduct
photo testing and debugging to ensure a
robust and reliable remote execution
environment and the next is
compatibility upgrades ensure
compatibility with the latest checking
release and keep up the remoting module
up to date with the evolving Jenkins
ecosystem this involves adapting to new
plugins apis and other changes
introduced in Jenkins and the next
objective for this project is
streamlined communication Implement
efficient communication protocols
between Jenkins master and agents to
reduce overhead and enhance data
transfer speeds evaluate potential
improvements such as binary
serialization and optimized data
exchange then we have error handling and
Reporting enhance error handling
capabilities in the remote system to
provide more informative and action 11
error messages this will assist users in
diagnosing and resolving issues properly
and the next is feature expansion
explore opportunities to extend the
capabilities of Jenkins remodeling this
may involve adding new features like
agent Auto Discovery Dynamic scaling of
Agents or support for additional build
environments so if we just conclude the
project that improved Jenkins remoting
project aims to elevate the performance
security and functionality of Jenkins
remote execution capabilities by
addressing existing limitations and
introducing new features the project
will contribute to a more robust and
efficient CI CD code system enhancing
the overall experience for Jenkins users
and hosting continuous Improvement
within the devs community
so this was our first project and it
should and it is a beginner project
which you can showcase on your resume
and now moving on we'll see the second
project that is creating a simple web
server
so first we'll have a overview of the
project over the project description
so this project aims to demonstrate the
process of setting up a basic web server
using modern devops practices the
project will utilize a variety of tools
and Technologies to automate the
deployment configuration and management
of the web server by following this
project participants will gain insights
into how Dev principles streamline the
software development life cycle enabling
faster more reliable and efficient
application delivery and now we will
talk about the project objectives
so the first is infrastructure
provisioning the project will ensure
provisioning the necessary
infrastructure to host the web server
this includes selecting a cloud platform
example AWS Azure and gcp and setting up
virtual machines or containers to run
the server the next is Version Control
Version Control will be used to manage
the project source code it will be the
Version Control System of choice
allowing for collaboration code
management and easy rollback to previous
versions if necessary and the next is
configuration management
configuration management tools example
ansible puppet Chef will be employed to
automate the installation and setup of
the web server software this ensures
consistency across environments and
simplifies the deployment process and
the next is continuous integration and
continuous deployment the project will
Implement CI CD pipelines using tools
such as Jenkins gitlab CI CD or private
CI automated testing and deployment
pipelines will be established to speed
up the deployment process and ensure
code quality and the next objective is
monitoring and logging monitoring tools
like formsus or refiner will be
integrated to keep track of the web
server's performance and health logging
Solutions like elk stack elasticsearch
log stash Ibana will be used to gather
and analyze logs for troubleshooting and
debugging and the next objective is
security
security practices will be implemented
throughout the project to protect the
web server from potential threats this
includes managing user access enabling
firewalls and applying security patches
regularly the next is scalability a
project will consider the server's
scalability to handle increased traffic
and load strategies like load balancing
and auto scaling will be explored to
ensure Optimal Performance under varying
conditions and what this project
delivers is that at the end of the
project you guys will have successfully
created a simple web server and deployed
it using modern devops tools and
methodologies they will have gained
hands-on experience in provisioning
infrastructure Version Control
configuration management CI CD pipelines
monitoring locking security
implementation and scalability
considerations now moving to a third
project that is create default base
images with token so we will have an
overview of this project so the create
default base images of the docker
project is a devs initiative aimed at
streamlining the process of creating
default base images using Docker
containers it revolves around optimizing
the development and deployment workflow
by providing a consistent and efficient
foundation for various applications and
services
sudoka like now we'll talk about
something
and a brief about the docker so Docker
is a popular containerization technology
that allows developers to package
applications and their dependencies into
lightweight portable containers
now we'll see the project benefits or
their objectives
so the first objective is consistency
with standardized base images all
applications run on a uniform
environment reducing compatibility
issues and unexpected Behavior across
different deployment stages the next is
Time Savings developers no longer need
to configure the environment from sketch
for each application using the
pre-configured base images saves the
time and effort leading to faster
development Cycles the next is improved
security by adding to security best
practices and base image creation the
organization can minimize potential
vulnerabilities and enhance overall
application security and the next is
scalability
the project allows for scalability and
flexibility as more applications can
leverage the same base images reducing
resource consumption and simplifying
infrastructure management and the next
is Version Control and rollbacks
poisoning Docker files and base images
enable easy rollbacks to previous
working States in case of issues or bugs
and the next we have is automated builds
integrating the base image creation
process into the CI CD Pipeline and
shows automated and continuous building
testing and deployment enhancing the
development workflow and the next
objective for this project is reduce
deployment errors standardized face
images help identify and resolve issues
early in the development process
reducing the likelihood of Errors during
deployment and the next is portability
Docker containers build on the base
images can run consistently across
different environments from development
to production ensuring portability and
consistency so to the conclusion for
this project the create default base
images with Docker projects offers a
practical and effective approach to
streamline the software delivery process
by providing standardized secure and
automated base images the project
improves application development
deployment consistency and overall
software quality however to overcome
Channel changes and maximize benefits
effective collaboration regular
maintenance and continuous Improvement
are essential the successful
implementation of this project
organizations can achieve a more
efficient and reliable software
development life cycle meeting the
demands of today's Dynamic technology
landscape so that's why it's have been
important to keep this project on your
resume
and now for those looking to level up
their skills let's explore some
intermediate level doves project ideas
so starting with creating a CI CD
pipeline using Azure devops so in this
project we'll explore the world of
continuous integration and continuous
deployment cicd and how it can
streamline your software development and
deployment processes so first we'll
understand CI CD so to begin let's have
a brief overview of CI so continuous
integration is a practice where code
changes are automatically built and
tested whenever they are pushed to
Version Control repository such as git
this ensures that the code is
continuously integrated and validated
caching potential issues early in the
development cycle and on the other hand
continuous development CD is the process
of automatically deploying the code to
production environments after passing
through the CI phase CD eliminates
manual interventions and ensure fast and
reliable software releases and this is
what we know about CI and CD Now we will
have an introduction to Azure devops so
Azure devops is a powerful cloud-based
platform that provides a set of tools
and services for software development
including Version Control build
Automation and release management Azure
devops offers a seamless and integrated
environment for implementing CI CD
Pipelines and the project goals are that
is to set up a CI CD pipeline using
Azure devops for a sample application we
will demonstrate the end-to-end process
of automatically building testing and
deploying the application to various
environments including staging and
production
now we'll talk about the project goals
or the project objectives so the first
is automate the build process that is
set up an automated build process to
compile the source code and create
Deployable artifacts this ensures that
developers code changes this ensures
that developers code changes are
consistently built and tested the next
is automate testing Implement automated
testing to validate the application's
functionality and ensure the new changes
do not introduce regressions or bugs and
the next is continuous deployment
establish a seamless deployment process
that automates the release of
applications to different environments
example staging and production as soon
as they pass the required test and the
next we have is Version Control
integration integrate Version Control
System example kit with the CI CD
pipeline to manage source code changes
effectively and the next we have is
monitoring and feedback enable
monitoring and logging mechanisms to
provide feedback on the application's
performance and health during and after
deployment so for the conclusion of this
project you can create a CI CD pipeline
using Azure devops that's an excellent
project to Showcase your devops skills
and expertise by mastering cicd
pipelines you will be well equipped to
deliver software with speed reliability
and efficiency and the next project we
have in our pocket for intermediate
levels are Implement devs life cycle
with Amazon web services that is AWS
so we will have a brief introduction
that is the project implementing devops
lifecycle with Amazon web services
focuses on integrating the principles
and practices of devops into the
software development and deployment
process using the AWS platform devops is
a collaborative approach that emphasizes
seamless communication and cooperation
between development and operations team
aimed at delivering high quality
software at a private Pace by leveraging
AWS services and tools this project aims
to automate streamline and optimize the
software development drive cycle
so now you'll see the project objectives
why we should consider this project
so the first objective is seamless
collaboration poster culture of
collaboration between development and
operation scheme breaking down
traditional silos to enable continuous
feedback and Improvement throughout the
software development process and the
next is Automation and efficiency
utilize AWS services and tools to
automate repetitive tasks such as code
deployment testing and infrastructure
provisioning to improve efficiency and
reduce manual errors and the next we
have is continuous integration and
continuous deployment cicd Implement CI
CD pipelines using AWS code pipeline
code build and code deployed to enable
frequent and Reliable Software releases
ensuring faster time to Market and
better customer satisfaction the next is
infrastructure s code utilize AWS cloud
formation or AWS cdk to Define
infrastructure as code allowing for
Version Control repeatable and
consistent infrastructure deployments
the next we have is monitoring and
logging Implement robust monitoring and
logging Solutions using AWS cloudwatch
and other services to gain real-time
insights into application performance
and operational metrics the next we have
is scalability and resilience leverage
AWS Auto scaling and load balancing
capabilities to ensure applications can
handle varying workloads and maintain
High availability and the next we have
is security and compliance Implement
security best practices using AWS
identity and access management IAM
encryption mechanisms and other AWS
security features to protect the
applications and data from potential
threats so these are the project
objectives we need to consider for
before building this project and now
we'll just have a conclusion about this
project that is the implementing devs
life cycle with Amazon web services
project enables organizations to embrace
a devops culture and take full advantage
of the AWS platform's capabilities so by
automating processes implementing CI CD
and enhancing collaboration the project
aims to accelerate software delivery
while maintaining high quality and
reliability additionally it establishes
a foundation for scalable secure and
resilient applications on the AWS cloud
and if you have all these skills you
will be easily employable with these
employers
so now moving on to next project that is
build a scale level application with
kubernetes and doco
so this project combines two powerful
Technologies kubernetes and offer to
create a highly scalable and efficient
application deployment system let's dive
in and take a closer look the main goal
of this project is to containerize your
application using Docker making it
portable and easy to manage then we will
utilize kubernetes a powerful container
or castration tool to manage and scale
your application effortlessly so first
we'll understand Docker that is before
we get started with kubernetes let's
understand the importance of dog doka is
a containerization platform that allows
you to package your application and its
dependencies into a single unit known as
a container these containers are
lightweight portable and can run
consistently across different
environments now we'll see what is
containerizing your application now
comes the exciting part contain Rising
your application we'll use Docker to
package your application ensuring it
runs smoothly and consistently across
various platforms this step simplifies
the deployment process making it easier
to manage and maintain your application
the next we have is Introduction to
kubernetes
whether application containerized it's
time to introduce kubernetes kubernetes
is an open source container
orchestration platform that automates a
deployment scaling and management of
containerized applications it provides a
robust ecosystem for managing
microservices and scalable applications
now we'll see how we can deploy our
application so deploying your
application with kubernetes is a game
changer kubernetes takes charge of
managing your containers and showing
there and efficiently and remain highly
available you can easily scale your
application up or down based on the
demand making it ideal for handling
varying workloads now we'll see the
managing application updates one of the
most significant advantage of kubernetes
is its ability to manage application
updates seamlessly with kubernetes you
can roll out updates without any
downtime ensuring smooth transition for
your users kubernets also enhances the
high availability and full tolerance of
your application by replicating your
application's containers across multiple
nodes kubernetes ensures that your
application stays accessible even if
some nodes fail and another powerful
feature of kubernetes is the horizontal
Port autoscaler HP the HPA automatically
adjusts the number of replicas based on
the application CPU usage or other
custom metrics this Dynamic scaling
keeps your application responsive under
varying workloads and the next is
monitoring and login monitoring and
logging are crucial in a production
environment kubernetes integrates with
various monitoring and logging Solutions
like promoters and Elk stack enabling
you to keep track of your application's
performance and troubleshoot any issues
effectively and now we'll see some of
the benefits of this project that is
building a scalable application with
kubernetes and Dockers over several
benefits that is efficient deployment
scalability High availability for
tolerance and I will conclude this
project that is the exciting build a
scalable application with kubernetes and
Docker project that is by containerizing
your application with both these you'll
have a highly efficient and scalable
application deployment system and now
we'll move to Advanced helps project
ideas and we'll start with creating a
monitoring dashboard for an application
so first we'll have an overview of this
project the goal of this devs project is
to develop and Implement a monitoring
dashboard for an application the
monitoring dashboard will provide
real-time insights and visualizations
into the application's performance
health and key metrics by setting up a
robust monitoring system the development
and operations teams can proactively
identify and address issues and show
Optimal Performance and make data driven
decisions to improve the application's
reliability and user experience now
we'll talk about the key objectives of
this project the first is monitoring
setup the first step involves setting up
the monitoring infrastructure this may
include selecting appropriate monitoring
tools and Technologies such as home this
graphene elk stack elasticsearch log
stats or other Solutions based on
specific requirements of the project the
next is data collection once the
monitoring tools are in place the next
objective is to configure them to
collect relevant data from the
application and its underlying
infrastructure data sources may include
server logs application logs performance
metrics error dates database queries and
other relevant data points the next is
and the next is dashboard design the
core of the project is designing a
visually informative and user-friendly
dashboard a dashboard should present the
collected data in a meaningful and easy
to understand format it should include
charts graphs tables and visual elements
that provide real-time insights into the
application's health and performance the
next is altering mechanism setting up an
opening mechanism is crucial for
notifying the relevant stakeholders
whenever certain predefined thresholds
or anomalies are detected alerts can be
configured to be sent through email
instant messaging platforms or other
communication channels the next is
scalability considerations in a real
world scenario applications May scale
horizontally or vertically based on user
demand the monitoring dashboard should
be designed to handle such scaling
scenarios without compromising on
performance and data accuracy the next
is security and access control and the
next we have is documentation and
training and the next is continuous
Improvement that is monitoring
requirements can evolve over time and in
conclusion by creating this monitoring
dashboard for the application the
project aims to provide actionable
insights timely alerts and a
comprehensive view of the application's
performance and health
this will empower the devops team to
proactively address issues optimized
resources and ensure the application
meets its performance and reliability
targets ultimately leading to improved
user satisfaction and a more efficient
development process now moving to the
next project that is deploy a
containerized application
so first we'll have an overview of this
project that is in the deploy a
containerized application devs project
we focus on the process of
containerizing and deploying a web
application using Docker and kubernetes
this project is ideal for intermediate
level devs Engineers or the advanced
level we are talking about the advanced
levels that are looking to enhance their
skills in containerization and container
orchestration so first we will have a
little understanding of the project that
is we aim to take a web application and
package it as a Docker container Docker
containers offer a lightweight portable
and consistent environment for
applications to run ensuring that they
work seamlessly across different
platforms the Project's primary goal is
to demonstrate how containerization
simplifies its application deployment
and scalability now we'll see the
setting of the project that is these are
the steps to setting up a project so
first is contain Rising the web
application the next is building and
pushing the docker image and the third
is deploying the containerized
application that is setting up the
kubernetes cluster then we have
deploying the application to kubernetes
and then exposing the application with a
service so benefits and learning what
the outcomes of this project are
throughout this project participants all
the people who want to do this project
will gain valuable knowledge and
experience in various areas that is
containerization container orchestration
Dev principles scalability and high
availability
so in conclusion this project is an
excellent Dev project for those looking
to level up their containerization and
orchestration skills by completing this
project participants will have a solid
understanding of container-based
deployments and the benefits of using
kubernetes for managing containerized
applications and remember Hands-On
experiences invaluable in the devs field
so moving on to the last project that is
automate kubernetes cluster deployment
with terraform
so first we'll have an overview that is
the automate kubernetes cluster
deployment with terraform project is a
devops initiative aimed at streamlining
the process of setting up and managing
kubernetes clusters using terraform
kubernetes has become a popular
container orchestration platform due to
its flexibility scalability and
robustness however setting up a
kubernetes cluster manually can be
complex and time consuming this project
addresses this challenge by leveraging
terraforms infrastructure as code
capabilities to automate the entire
cluster development process so now we'll
see the key objectives of this project
that is infrastructure as code
that is emphasizing the use of terraform
a declarative language to define the
desired taste or state of the kubernetes
cluster infrastructure the next is
automated kubernetes cluster
provisioning the next is customizability
and flexibility then we have multi-cloud
support that is ensuring compatibility
with various Cloud providers then we
have integrating with best practices
that is incorporating kubernetes best
practices and security standards
then we have some key features that is
the project includes the following key
features terraform configuration files
then variable management provider
plugins networking and security
kubernetes deployment continuous
integration and continuous deployment so
these are the benefits and in conclusion
this project empowers organizations to
rapidly and reliably set up kubernetes
clusters in a repeatable and efficient
manner by leveraging terraforms
capabilities the project brings
automation consistency and flexibility
to the kubernetes deployment process
ultimately enhancing the overall
efficiency and reliability of the
application developments life cycle and
congratulations you have explored a
range of Dove's project ideas that will
enrich your resume and make you more
desirable to employers remember the key
is to select projects aligned with your
interest and career goals working on
these projects will not only boost your
technical skills but also demonstrate
your commitment to becoming a proficient
devs engineer keep learning keep
building
and this was all for this tutorial hope
you guys found it informative and
helpful let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers I
started my It Journey with Accenture
three years ago I joined there as a
cloud architect there I worked with AWS
and Azure Technologies looking for
higher paying job and devops seem the
right career choice so I decided to go
with the postgraduate program in devops
in collaboration with Caltech ctme the
course was divided into modules
and we had assignments
I was really impressed by how many job
interviews I landed after I added the
certification to my portfolio and now I
am earning 40 more than my previous job
it didn't only boost my career but also
my confidence
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
question then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign